We've made a map,
we've put some information on it,
now let's make it yours.
If you're designing a website just for
fun or for
a specific business purpose, the feeling
you want to portray can differ widely.
>> Much like your personal fashion
choices, the style you apply to your map
can say a lot about the feeling
of your company or site.
>> It can also help direct the user's
attention to the things that you
want to stand out.
>> It can reflect the classiness of
business or site that you're creating.
>> Or it can simply be
a matter of personal taste.
>> In any case, you'll want to make
it your own by applying styling.
>> Google Maps come with a standard
style that most people are very
familiar with.
The things that we're able to change
about it are called features.
And they include things like water, land
features, roads such as highways and
local roads, points of interest, and
all the labels associated with them.
Let's check out a few
examples of styled maps.
First, here's a simple example.
We've changed the water to red and
set the hue of the whole
map to the same color.
We've also turned off all the labels.
Here's a pretty cool grey scale map.
This could be great if you want to
draw attention to only a few color
details like markers.
This is a good example of
a functionally styled map.
The user only sees the road elements.
These samples are all from Snazzy Maps
and awesome site for pre-built styles.
It's linked to the instructor notes.
>> Whatever you want to do,
you can do it.
Let's make our own custom style.
>> We'll create a styles array
in our initialize function.
Styled maps use two concepts to
apply colors and changes to a map.
Map features are the geographic elements
that can be targeted on the map.
Roads, parks, bodies of water, etc.
Elements are what about that
feature that you want to change.
The geometry itself, the label,
the label outliner text.
Stylers are the color and
visibility properties that can
be applied to the map features.
Map features and stylers
are combined into the styles array.
Styles are cascading.
So for example, if you make all the rows
red and then choose to make highways
blue, you'll get blue highways and
red local and arterial roads.
Also, unless you choose a style,
the map will stick with the defaults.
We can craft styles from scratch but
there's also a ton of great and
free options online
that give you starters.
And from there you can change
the colors, add and remove stuff,
make it your own.
Just google search for
Google Maps API Styles.
I'm using a set of styles
here I found online.
But I've made the transit
station stand out more.
At the same time, we'll set the styles
property within the map object options.
Now, in addition to a zoom and
a center, the map object gets a set of
styles which we've defined above it.
The map type controls parameter allows
the user to change the map type to road,
terrain, satellite, etc.
So we're disabling that
by setting it to false.
While we're being fancy, we'll jazz up
the markers a bit to match our map.
I'm creating two new marker icons here.
One is the default icon which
will appear when the markers
appear on the map.
And one that's a highlighted icon which
will appear when I hover over a marker.
I've created a simple function
below to take in a color and
create a marker icon object.
This make marker icon function
simply takes in a marker color and
creates a new marker image
using that marker color and
using some custom sizes and what not.
Then, I'm going to go back to our loop
where we create all of our markers and
set the icon on each
marker to default icon.
Finally, I'm going to
add two event listeners.
One for a mouseover event to change
our icon to the highlighted icon.
And one for the mouseout event to
change it back to the default icon.
This is going to make the marker
yellow when I mouseover it and
then turn it back to blue
when I mouseout of it.
I only have a few markers, so
this may not be totally necessary.
But if I had hundreds,
this would definitely help
the user select the correct icon.
Wow, that's a pretty funky looking map.
I hope you guys like
neon as much as I do.
Before you try it out yourself,
let's talk about one more
cool feature of styling.
Custom map types.
This sample let's the user toggle
between different styles.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
For a real estate app, we can enable
map types, for example, that can let
the user decide make subways and
transit stops stand out, focus
on neighborhood boundaries, or highlight
parks and other points of interest.
Click on the link in the instructor
notes to see this sample.
Next, try out creating your own styles.